[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys weltreise
gibt es ein grundrezept ich werde
nämlich nudeln machen also passé ich
habe neulich auf instagram schon
gepostet dass ich besser machen werde
und an schrieben die türkische
zuschauerin managers habe ich mich schon
gefreut aus dem kuchen kommt weil pasta
heißt auch türkisch kuchen als auf
deutsche gesetze kuchen aber heute gibt
ich will jetzt nicht sagen italienische
pasta aber wir machen nudeln nudeln kann
man ja wirklich in allen variationen
machen man kann auch mit der pastor
fresken machen also höhere nudeln usw
pirelli heute möchte ich aber mit den
nudeln walzen arbeiten und mit einem
teil besteht aus zwei und mehl und
hartweizen gries ich habe hier
verschiedene varianten dh ihr bekommt
zuerst main standard rezept ein grund
type und dann gibt es noch verschiedene
ausführungen und ich zeige euch wie man
die suppe einfach herstellen kann und
welche tipps und tricks ihr beachten
solltet damit ihr euch gelingen um
nudeln selber herzustellen frottier gar
nicht viele zutaten ich habe jetzt hier
welche stehen und zwar habe ich hier ein
ganz normales weizenmehl ich habe
olivenöl etwas salzig habe ich eier und
hier habe ich sie mir simona das ist ein
hartweizengrieß und das wird auch sehr
sehr gehalten sich sozusagen das bekommt
man im italienischen supermarkt oder
auch in großen supermärkten in der
italienischen abteilung hartweizengrieß
kann man auch selber ganz fein mahlen
also auch wenn ich dass man nicht zu
hause habe dann nehme ich einfach
hartweizengrieß geht es durch die
getreidemühle damit ein bisschen feiner
wird und ich so grob ist und dann kann
man das auch wunderbar mit dem mehr
vermischen
ich habe ende jetzt beides zu gleichen
teilen also 500 gramm normales mehl 500
gramm hartweizengrieß sehr wohl ich muss
aber auch dazu sagen als ich vor drei
jahren gemacht haben uns einfach nicht
besser wusste habe ich auch einfach
nudeln aus normalem mehl gemacht geht
auch gut aber durch das hartweizengrieß
bekommen die nudeln in besseren bis und
werden einfach nicht so weich und so
letztlich und deswegen solltet ihr es
auf jeden fall mal ausprobieren
ich mache es immer so auf 100 gramm
trockene masse als auf 100 gramm von
diesem gemisch kommt 1 1 etwas olivenöl
und salz beim salz ist immer so ein
thema mancher sagen kein salz in der
nudelteig weil sich sonst fett und
männlich verbinden
andere sagen doch mit rein und ich habe
jetzt schon berührt beides klappt super
deswegen gebe ich mit rein weil einfach
der geschmack von anfang an direkt
besser wird ich kenne den nudelteig geht
es in der küchenmaschine man kann auch
mit der hand kneten aber die konsistenz
sollte natürlich relativ fest sein weil
ich dadurch die walze gebe und dann das
ausrollen einfacher ist und mit der hand
ist einfach ein bisschen anstrengen also
ich gebe es hier 500 gramm mehl 1 500
gramm simulator olivenöl und bei den
eiern ist es auch so es gibt natürlich
auch nudeln ohne könnt ihr auch
herstellern einfach nur mit wasser und
hartweizengrieß so ist sind auch die
meisten nudeln die man kauft von barilla
zum beispiel durch die eier hat man
natürlich eine andere konsistenz eine
bessere bindung und gerade für anfänger
ist besser geeignet und ich muss sagen
ich mag den ein geschmack in nudeln sei
jetzt die eier dazu und dann noch salz
und durch die eier bekommen die nudel
natürlich auch eine richtig tolle farbe
die kann man aber auch zum beispiel
durch kurkuma machen
hier ist also jetzt der basic nudelteig
der wird jetzt verknetet er sollte eine
richtig schöne feste konsistenz haben
nicht zu weich sein wenn er aber doch zu
trocken ist mal die eier zum beispiel zu
klein waren könnte so ein schlückchen
wasser dazugeben aber lieber erstmal
ohne wasser kneten
jetzt heißt zum beispiel dass die
maschine sehr angestrengt geknetet und
jetzt sehe ich auch das ist nicht gut
verbindet und gibt teelöffel weise jetzt
wasser dazu bisschen schöner großer klub
mensch steht jetzt ist der teig fertig
und er muss auch noch nicht glatt
aussehen also man merkt man auch wenn
man in die hand nimmt und so ein
bisschen knetet es ist ein schöner
geschmeidiger teig und wie gesagt so
weicht davon nicht sein wenn ich jetzt
keine küchenmaschine habe mache ich das
ganze eher andersherum
also ich nehme dann eher 100 gramm
weniger mehl mischung und gebt dann erst
mal die zähne rein und bisschen weniger
mehl und dann kann ich einfach bei
bedarf noch das mehl 1 kneten weil es
ein bisschen schonen und da ich für
meine ellenbogen und natürlich auch ein
bisschen einfacher so den teig kann ich
jetzt einmal zu einer kugel zusammen
fassen ist aber noch ein bisschen
ich mache jetzt zwei portionen und bevor
ich dir nicht weiter verarbeiten musste
er in den kühlschrank für mindestens
eine stunde dann kann er schön ausgeruht
weiterverarbeitet werden oder auch
einfach über nacht und während der
geburt zeige ich euch noch ein paar
variationen wie man nudelteig ein
bisschen aufpeppen kann
jetzt machen mit grünen nudeln die mache
ich jetzt mit basilikum
hier könnt ihr natürlich alle kräuter
nehmen die im garten haben die ihr gerne
mögt ihr könnt auch spinat verwenden
wichtig ist jetzt nur wenn man eine
andere zutat dazu gibt wie basilikum zum
beispiel tomatenmark oder rote beete das
mal weniger flüssigkeit verwendet also
ein weniger oder einfach mehr mehl und
damit ich den basilikum mit gute den
teig rein bekomme muss ich ihnen
zerkleinern dafür kommt da jetzt hier in
einen kleinen mixa jetzt da einfach die
kräuter gewürzmühle und damit sich das
schönste kleidern kann fühle ich da
einfach ein bisschen mit dazu und habe
dann eine schöne sämige passte das öl
kann auch noch mit rein
[Musik]
so sieht jetzt da war silikon nudelteig
aus und hier seht ihr mal was ich noch
so alles hier in der küche kreiert habe
ich habe ganz viele nudel kreationen ich
habe ich den normalen tag das sieht so
richtig schön gelb aus dass sie dabei
ein bisschen blass aus wenn man dann
eben den teig hat mit kurkuma ich habe
ich kurkuma einfach als pulver verwendet
und habe sogar noch ein bisschen
currypulver einfach in den teig geknetet
so habe ich eine richtig schöne farbe
und auch ein ganz tolles aroma dieser
teig hier ist entstanden mit tomatenmark
und chili und hier muss man auch darauf
achten dass er mit tomatenmark dazu gibt
ein ei vorwegnimmt und daneben die menge
dadurch ersetzt richtig schön und die
chiliflocken die gefallen mir richtig
gut
hier habe ich den rote beete nudelteig
und zwar habe ich dafür ganz frische
rote beete genommen die verarbeite ich
immer gerne mit handschuhen weil sie
einfach sonst meine hände verwerten weil
es war nicht schlimm wenn ich
pinkfarbene hände habe aber nicht so
ganz schön und dafür habe ich dann die
rote beete einfach fein geraspelt und im
wasser ein bisschen gekocht oder so
schön weich wird die gras bitten und
gekochten rote beete stücke die werden
dann noch püriert und auch einfach durch
ein oder zwei eier ersetzt je nachdem
wie intensive das ganze haben möchte
ich habe hier noch ein paar rote beete
stückchen mit dabei das finde ich gar
nicht schlimm wenn ihr die nicht haben
möchtet müsst ihr das pury einfach nur
mal durch ein sieb streichen so dass es
richtig fein wird
da gefällt mir extrem gut hier habe ich
vollkornnudeln und dafür habe ich
einfach weizen genommen selbst gemahlen
ihr könnt natürlich auch vollkornmehl
ihm einfach kaufen und da eben schöne
vollkornnudeln zubereiten und hier und
ich glaube das wird mir ganz gut
gefallen habe ich einen nutella teig und
da habe ich auch zwei eier weggelassen
und diese durch nutella ersetzt um den
teig geknetet
natürlich habe ich hier nur eine prise
salz mit dabei und das schauen wir mal
später wie die uns schmecken
die werden dann nämlich in milch gekocht
und auf die idee bin ich gekommen weil
es gibt so ein rezept und arme leute
rezept milch nudeln
vielleicht könnt ihr immer schreiben ob
ihr das kennt ich kannte es nicht das
haben wir mal zuschauer geschrieben
da werden einfach nur den im mint
gekocht und mit vanille zucker gegessen
und ich denke wenn man das mit den
nutella nudelteig macht dann hat man
sogar gleich noch ein kabel hergestellt
und kommt auf schlürfen
also ich lasse stets kurz ruhen holt
gleich meine pasta walzen her
und dann nudeln wir zusammen jetzt zeige
ich euch wie aus den teichen nudeln
entstehen ich verwende dafür diese
walzen nudel walzen
ich habe eine lasagne walze also für die
normalen platten und dann habe ich noch
zwei schneide walzen und zwar hier
einmal fett schiene und spaghetti die
unterscheiden sich in der breite da gibt
es natürlich auch noch andere die
unterschiedlich breit schneiden
wichtig ist wenn ihr fett china oder
spaghetti machen wollte man die lasagne
weil sie unbedingt denn der teig muss
erstmal ausgerollt werden also das ist
so
die basic variante und danach kann man
aufbauen wenn man möchte nur den kann
man natürlich auch mit dem ausrollen
starb ausrollen aber dass es sehr mühsam
weil es einfach ein fester teig ist
wichtig ist jetzt nur nicht so viel teig
auf einmal nehmen lieber kleinere
portionen und die knete ich jetzt vorher
kurz weil ihr könnt sie auch wenn ihr
möchtet damit es ein bisschen schneller
geht vorher kurz plattwalzen roubini
merkel sind bisschen klebrig einfach
bisschen mehl oder symbole oder beides
vermischt verwenden jetzt fangt ihr bei
der dicksten einstellung an
und dann immer dünner also hier bei mir
ist die dickste einstellung einfach
stufe 0 und dann die geschwindigkeit
wäre da nicht so schnell der name ist
hier auch dementsprechend schnell dann
die teigplatten wieder auffangen
da oben rein
und jetzt den teig falken denn ich
möchte eine schöne platte war allem
möchte ich außen den schönen rand und
wenn euch die platte dann gefällt da
haben die stufe ändern und den teig
dünner walten
ich gebe meine pasta war also immer
gerne bis stufe 4
ihr müsst einfach selber entscheiden wie
dünn oder dick ihr die nudeln gerne
haben möchte
das lege ich jetzt hier kurz zur seite
und ich bereit ist auch immer erst alles
kurz vor und dann schneidig da muss ich
einfach nicht ständig hin und her
[Musik]
durch das mehrmalige falten und wieder
durchlassen bewegt man einfach dass die
nudel platte schön gleichmäßig wird und
dass sich eben auch die volle breite der
nudel walser ausnutze ansonsten bekommt
man nämlich ebenso ein stück raus und
hat einfach auch viel viel mehr arbeit
jetzt geht es ans schneiden dh die
lasagne weil sie hat ihre arbeit getan
ich nehme jetzt einfach die spaghetti
walze und auch die vierte maschine und
kann das ganze jetzt hier durchlaufen
bevor ich schneide überlege ich mir
natürlich wie lange sollen denn die
nudeln werden und dementsprechend
schneide ich mit platten zu so wie hier
vorne hier und dann können wir die nudel
länger oder auch kürzer gestalten
die geschwindigkeit für das so
einstellen dass sie auch hinterher kommt
aber schneller hände hat kann auch ein
bisschen höher einstellen und entweder
nimmt jetzt die hände
das heißt hier oben rein geben ihr könnt
sie runterfallen lassen und als nest
hintern trocknen oder ihr nehmt die hand
so und geht dann zum beispiel zu sondern
nudeltopf darüber zusammen ständer erst
alleine wird auch funktionieren oder wir
nehmen euch ein stäbchen
das geht auch gut
dann hier auffangen was rüber damit
überlegen und dann den spielt einfach um
indirekt ziehen
bei den nets sind einfach nur aufpassen
dass sie schön trocken sind sie dürfen
eben nicht zusammenkleben
[Musik]
die kleinen teig reste die lasse ich
immer noch gerne durch und machte hier
so eine suppe nudel mischung für die
kinder vor allem cd super bund aus und
ich kann jetzt hier auf einer dauerhaft
folie wie hier einfach trocknen lassen
und dann bei bedarf sondern gemüsesuppe
dazu geben oder auch den nudeln einfach
als bunte kleine nudel mischung abkochen
und für samira und ella machen
ich habe jetzt hier den nudeln auf dem
ständer und die last jetzt einfach nur
ein bisschen an trocknen und dann nimmt
er sie herunter was die jungs sind sogar
schon ein bisschen so lange sie noch
flexibel sind lassen sie sich nämlich
besser unternehmen wenn sie nämlich ganz
durch trocknen dann brechen sie beim
unternehmen
aber hier könnt ihr sehen
so klappt's noch ganz gut und dann lege
ich sie einfach hier auf ein weiter auf
eine weitere dauer back folie und lasse
dann über nacht manchmal dauert auch
zwei bis drei tage einfach bei
raumtemperatur stehen ihr könnt den
trocknungs vorgang auch ein bisschen
beschleunigen wenn ihr es einfach in den
ofen gibt bei heißluft bei ganz
niedriger temperatur etwa 30 bis 40 grad
immer mal wieder der offen tür öffnen
aber so kann man das ganze stromsparend
einfach auch trocknen und kommt einfach
darauf an wie feucht es bei euch zu
hause ist im sommer trocknen sie bei mir
immer ein bisschen schneller als im
winter da ist es oft bei uns in der
wohnung hier vor allem sei es erfolgt
jetzt noch ein paar fragen wie lange
kann man nudeln aufbewahren
also wenn sie im prinzip komplett
durchgetrocknet sind ist es ja so wie
gekaufte nudeln ich würde jetzt nicht
ewig aufheben weil ja auch ein mit drin
steckt aber wenn sie ganz
durchgetrocknet sind dann klappt das
wunderbar eine andere zuschauerin hatte
das problem dass die nudeln nach dem
schneiden schnell wieder zusammenkleben
und es hängt einfach damit zusammen dass
der teig von vornherein einfach ein
bisschen zu feucht war und bei lasagne
platten zum beispiel ist es nicht so
schlimm
bei thalia teller ist es auch nicht ganz
so schlimm aber spätestens bei spaghetti
versagt ihr dann denn dann kleben die
not und sofort wieder zusammen und die
geht echt nicht mehr auseinander
also da muss der teig konsistenz auf
jeden fall immer stimmen und die nudeln
werden dann ganz normal in kochendem
salzwasser gekocht und ich lass dir
einfach immer so lange kochen bis er an
der oberfläche schwimmen
ich probiere sie natürlich ich mag sie
gerne al dente also bis es die dürfen
nicht ganz zu weich sein aber bei den
nudeln mit seemüller oder
hartweizengrieß passiert es sowieso
nicht ganz
schnell die nudeln könnt ihr dann
wirklich richtig cool aufpeppen mit
einer soße wobei ich finde dass zb die
basilikum nudeln oder auch die tomaten
und rote beete nudeln sowieso genug
eigengeschmack haben da brauche ich dann
nur noch ein bisschen olivenöl
vielleicht knoblauch im park gewürze und
das reicht mir dann schon
ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim nudeln
falls ihr fragen habt zur nudel walze da
könnt ihr einfach mal auf meinem technik
kanal schauen da kommt nämlich ein video
darüber online also viel spaß beim
nachmachen beim rodeln kann man das so
sagen egal ihr wisst was ich meine
ich wünsche euch viel spaß beim
nachmachen und gesehen und wieder das
nächste mal süß
[Musik]
die nutella nudeln die habe ich hier
übrigens gerade in milch abgekocht da
kommt jetzt noch ein guter schuss orgel
extrakt drin ein kleines treppchen
und jetzt bin ich mal gespannt also
mutterland
da bin ich ja echt nur auf die idee
gekommen wegen euren milch nudeln und
einmal probieren schmeckt ihr bildungs
mit wichtig dabei ist kann man machen
muss man aber nicht